die linke mit unserer situation und
total anders ist als ein normaler
schulbetrieb statement sie sich mal 34
bevor sie hunger muss community
gemeinschaft aufbauen bevor die
funktionieren immer große thema noch
immer prallen welten aufeinander wenn
junge indianer aus ihren dörfern in die
stadt ziehen
wie gelingt es ausgerechnet einem
schweizer zwischen diesen welten zu
vermitteln
davon handelt dieser film
während es stimmt sie lebt seit über 20
jahren in kanada
er hilft jugendlichen in die augen auf
ihrem schwierigen weg zum high school
abschluss
[Musik]
der flughafen der kleinstadt zeox
lookout in ontario kanada
sagt man so lookout hier wollt werden
das stimmt sie zum beginn des semesters
seine schützlinge ab der weg dieser
jugendlichen ist nicht nur schwierig er
ist auch weit über hunderte von
kilometern reisen sie an um in der stadt
die high school zu besuchen
in ihren dörfern gibt es keine high
school
darum müssen die jugendlichen aus ihrer
vertrauten umgebung mit den engen
familienbanden in die stadt kommen
wir werden sie in gastfamilien leben
gregory anderson hatte letztes jahr
große probleme
alkohol drogen der 18 jährige flog von
der schule
jetzt soll es endlich packen darum wird
er unter besonderer obhut bei werner
stähli
als ich in meiner kindheit indianer
spielte mimte ich stolze helden die
keine furcht kennen die indianer die ich
heute treffe sind scheue verunsicherte
jugendliche
[Musik]
zu lookout hat nur 5000 einwohner für
die jugendlichen aus den kleinen
indianer dörfern ist es eine großstadt
das blockhaus von werner stimmt sie
liegt außerhalb der stadt vor einiger
zeit wohnte gregory schon einmal hier
weit weg von den gefährlichen
verlockungen gregory verkriecht sich
sofort in sein zimmer und besuchte als
erstes die facebook seite seiner mutter
ein junger mann hin und hergerissen
zwischen coolness und heimweh
während sich frau heidi arbeitet als
krankenschwester
sie weiß mit gregor s verhalten
umzugehen
das schweizer paar nimmt immer wieder
jugendliche weil sich auf die auf
besonders schwierig gelten
der erste schultag des neuen semesters
als highschool bezeichnet man die
letzten vier jahre der obligatorischen
schulzeit ohne abschluss ist es
schwierig einen job zu finden
ein drittel der schüler gehört der first
nations den ureinwohnern kanadas männer
stand sie ist eine mischung aus
nachhilfe lehrer und sozialarbeiter
er arbeitet im auftrag mehrerer in die
andere als der job ausgeschrieben war
hat er es leicht
alle kannten ihn von unzähligen
kanutouren die er in indianer gebiet
geleitet hatte welcome to the new slogan
ich begrüße alle die nach den ferien
zurück sind und jene die zum ersten mal
hier sind
das ist euer zimmer hier helfen wir euch
wenn ihr sorgen habt oder probleme kommt
vorbei wir sind auch nach der schule
hier und helfen euch bei den
hausaufgaben kommt einfach vorbei
dafür sind wir hier und jetzt gibt's
erst einmal pizza
mich irritiert das verhalten der
jugendlichen ist es wirklich sinnvoll
dass hier fast alles erlaubt ist stunden
schwänzen überall handys die mützen tief
im gesicht und werden das stimmt sie
seelenruhig mittendrin
ich würde das eine fahrzeug langsam
langsam
slims doch am passieren für die
ausbildung ist ans aufgeben und eigen
dann ist es für die jugendlichen wirken
auf mich fast schon unflätig und
arrogant sie meiden direkten
blickkontakt das gilt dort aufdringlich
und in ihrer kultur ist es nicht üblich
direkte fragen zu stellen
ich versuche es trotzdem was willst du
nach der schule arbeiten
mechaniker oder elektriker weiß nicht
was dafür braucht es aber einen
schulabschluss würdest du lieber in
deinem dorf casa bonita oder hier ins
solebad arbeiten weiß nicht wo auch
immer vielleicht zu hause
die häufigste antwort die ich bekomme
schweigen niederschwellig akzeptieren so
beispiel in einer batterie und war mit
sorge in die euro-familie die da gibt es
viele pausen wo wir in europa würde man
die papiere zu überdecken und irgendwo
bedeutungslos ist das okay
ökonomie zack bismarck hat früher war
die erfolgsquote der jugendlichen
indianer miserabel
ein großteil flug irgendwann ohne
abschluss von der schule seit des werner
stützer hilfsangebot gibt ist die zahl
der schulabschlüsse markant gestiegen
viele der jugendlichen gelten als
schwierig und renitent vielleicht macht
sich aber einfach niemand die mühe sie
wirklich verstehen zu wollen sowie
werden stimmt sie das war jetzt kommen
auch die jugendliche das neue
mitstreiter sind und damit persönliche
probleme und das eigentliche situation
[Musik]
ich will die welt kennenlernen als der
diese jugendlichen kommen und bietet
gregory für ein wochenende mein
fremdenführer zu sein
der unverhoffte besuch in seinem dorf
macht den sonst so introvertierten
jungen überglücklich ich kann es kaum
erwarten
[Musik]
willkommen in kassel bei uniqa meine
heimat
[Musik]
nicht
ich lerne einen ganz anderen gregory
kennen einem herzlichen und offenen
jugendliche der sich riesig freut über
das wieder felix seinen geschwistern und
seiner mutter
[Musik]
casa bonita liegt einsam in einer
riesigen seenplatte unterhalb der hudson
bay
auch wer die highschool abgeschlossen
hat findet hier nur schwer einen job
das dorf hat gerade einmal 900 einwohner
[Musik]
während sie trifft einen ehemaligen
schüler handeln
das läuft so nicht viel
genieße meine freiheit gäste wieder in
die schule
ja ich habe mich angemeldet
wo willst du hin hier ein paar kurse
besuchen das ist alles was mir bleibt
ich werde dann zu alt seien viele punkte
fehlen die noch bis zum abschluss 20
wäre ich in so lukat geblieben hätte ich
21 machen können aber ich habe es
vermasselt
ja das stimmt dem reporter doch mal was
so schwierig war dass ich so weit weg
war von zu hause
ich war noch nie so lange weg ich denke
schon
was war damals los
keine ahnung habe einfach zu viel
getrunken
und warum hatte heimweh und der medien
körper über die schwerwiegende soziale
probleme
foto tobis buch alkoholismus und man
vergisst immer dass die meisten dass dir
das problem sie
nicht alle sind problemfälle aber alle
haben es schwer ins berufsleben
einzusteigen
gregory bruder cordell hat letztes jahr
seinen highschool-abschluss geschafft
einen job hat er noch nicht gefunden
trotzdem ist er ein vorbild für gregory
wie kommt das dass du hier so fröhlich
ist redest du lachst du zurück bist du
viel ruhiger ich weiß nicht ich bin
einfach glücklich zu hause bei meiner
familie zu sein ist ein ganz anderer
mensch hier
die generation von gregory und seinem
bruder muss ich eine völlig neue
identität schaffen
ihre vorfahren war und trapper jäger und
fischer walfang habe fasziniert iris
wüster übers land so tiere und pflanzen
und zehn spielfilme umgangsformen
freundlich endlich richtung
du hast dich sehr der lebensraum besser
passt oder das abgenommen ja das ist nur
26 werden wir verlangen von denen das
selbst vornimmt und haben dem land wo
man besprechen
[Gelächter]
kalina anderson hat letztes jahr bei den
sch'tis gewohnt heute lebt sie mit ihrem
sohn wieder im tor
sie hatte eine schwierige zeit in das
stand doch sie hat die high school
gemeistert werner stützer hat fotos der
abschlussfeier mitgebracht
[Musik]
immer wieder hatte carina anderson die
schule unterbrochen
statt vier jahre dauerte es neun jahre
bis sie ihren abschluss habe ich wusste
ich muss mich wirklich zusammen nehmen
ich hatte meiner mutter so versprochen
den abschluss zu machen und ich habe es
geschafft diese traurigkeit schwingt bei
vielen begegnungen mit
über generationen lebten die menschen in
der natur und von der natur heute
gratuliert man ihnen zu schulabschlüssen
die in ihrem leben noch vor wenigen
jahren nicht die geringste rolle spielen
doch die schule ist für diese kinder der
einzige weg in eine gute zukunft
[Musik]
zurück in so lookout bragas kleine
schwester christen hat ihre erste woche
in der neuen schule hinter sich
hast du deinen stundenplan dabei
[Musik]
hier ist ja hast du alle stunden besucht
seine lieblingsfächer mathe und musik
das ist cool du verstehst
lucia wo ich viel reißen ob ich mal
kinder wird weiß ich nicht
vor allem reisen will ich keine ahnung
wo es sich hölzl und hinzugehen
du willst die welt sehen ja scheint
spannend zu sein
ich habe in meinen büchern gesehen
[Musik]
jugendlichen interessieren sich für die
weite welt für alles was modern und
trendy ist
gleichzeitig sind sie tief verwurzelt in
ihrer tradition
[Musik]
stunden später die schule ist längst aus
von gregory fehlt jede spur
wo bist du bitte komm sofort zurück ok
wenn ein kollege macht weil er weiß dass
du musst mit mir fahre und so weist also
zieht musste sie das heißt wenn er nicht
da ist dann ist die chance groß dass ich
schwierigkeiten was schon vor ruhig
etwas was zuvor ich ja das könnte sie
das mofa und moped oder der rat
schwierigkeiten
wir erklären dass alkohol drogen groß
sind
es hat nur mit allgemeine situation
fotos und norden verlust von der kultur
so langsam früchte gott geht der traum
vieler lüth
[Musik]
was hast du mit ihr gemacht
er wohnt in mittweida
du hast gift
compact gehen wir